arctic air is blanketing the country's
midsection and it's putting tens of
millions of Americans at risk of
life-threatening cold this morning wind
chills in parts of the Midwest range
from negative 30 to negative 60 at least
six deaths are connected to the winter
storm the National Weather Service says
frostbite can set in within five minutes
at negative 50 windchill and within 15
minutes at negative 25 Don Dahler is in
Chicago we're already set new record for
the coldest temperature on this day Don
good morning yeah good morning it's
balmy here you can see where I didn't
lick Michigan that's the beautiful
skyline of Chicago this powerful arctic
blast that has descended on the city
could bring temperatures as low as
negative 60 windchill any exposed skin
during that time during that temperature
can get frostbite within 5 minutes so
I'm gonna be quick about this of course
the most vulnerable population are the
homeless people Chicago's home to about
16,000 of them so the city has put in
another 500 beds in their 160 shelters
around the city they've also made
available 5 city buses as temporary
warming shelters all of the city's 600
or so schools are closed today and
tomorrow because of these dangerous
temperatures that's impacting about
360,000 students and their families who
now have to figure out what to do with
them the National Weather Service
advises anybody who's out and having to
travel carry with them emergency
supplies including three days worth of
food and water just in case they get
stranded biana making me nervous just
standing out there get inside you didn't
reach that five minute mark with us
thankfully but we are thinking of those
most vulnerable and the coldest parts of
the country Thank You Don